beginnen wir mal das korrespondentennetz
von phoenix von ard und zdf intensiv zu
nutzen fangen an an der grenze von pol
zu belarus in kosice steht unser
korrespondent olaf bock herr bock wenn
ich das richtig mitbekommen habe sind
sie gerade in den letzten stunden erst
angekommen wie ist ihr eindruck was
sehen sie vor ort
naja das hier hinter ist eine kontrolle
zu diesem grenzübergang schnitzer also
der übergang zum belarus dieser
grenzübergang wurde heute morgen um 7
uhr zugemacht auslöser war dafür dass
eben viele menschen hier in dieser
region abseits dieses grenzübergangs
durch die wälder versucht haben richtung
polen zu gehen da und hat die polnische
seite entschieden dieser grenzübergang
wird jetzt komplett geschlossen
überhaupt ist der eindruck wenn man sich
hier in die grenzregion rein bewegt ich
bin ja mehrere male jetzt in vergangenen
wochen hier gewesen immer wieder
kontrollen und das was sich jetzt zeigt
ist dass immer mehr polizeiautos uns
sehr entgegengekommen sind also die
kräfte wurden intensiv verstärkt und das
wurde auch schon angekündigt es waren
erst 7000 menschen grenzschützer
soldaten dann wurde von 10.000
gesprochen und jetzt hat man nochmal
2000 weitere dazu geschickt also ja
dieses ganze grenzgebiet inklusive vorne
dem sperrgebiet ist sehr sehr gut
bewacht aus polnischer sicht eben
versucht man ja alle straßen zu
kontrollieren das ist eine abschottung
der europäischen außengrenzen ganz klar
von polnischer seite
ja es ist eine abschottung der grenze zu
europa die fakt ist ja sie haben es im
film ja auch eben würde schon gesehen
hier in den wäldern die weiterführen
nach belarus dort lagern menschen und
versuchen warten auf die chance nach
polen rüberzukommen es gab da gestern ja
leider auch unschöne szenen als menschen
dann versucht haben die zäune da
niederzureißen und die polnischen
grenzschützer haben tränengas zum
einsatz gebracht die sagen es sei im
moment drei bis viertausend menschen
allein in den wäldern die dort ausharren
und gestern nacht haben wir bilder
gesehen von
lagerfeuern zählten die aufgebaut worden
sind und unter diesen menschen
flüchtlinge und migranten sind männer
frauen aber auch kinder
und da stellt sich natürlich schon die
frage wie könnte das mit der humanitären
situation
in der zukunft aussehen denn die
temperaturen sind jetzt schon ziemlich
kalt und nachts geht es hier unter null
das wollte ich sie gerade fragen und ich
weiß natürlich dass hier nicht
rüberkommen nach belarus und da aber
trotzdem die frage nach dem was sie
hören was sie sehen was auch in sozialen
medien eben an videos kursiert wie geht
es diesen menschen dort sie haben ja
eben schon gesagt es geht um frauen
kinder und männer viele viele die dort
ausharren müssen gibt es überhaupt eine
versorgung in irgendeiner form gibt es
essen gibt es getränke gibt es überhaupt
möglichkeiten dass sie sich in
irgendeiner form warm halten können
bitte nehmen sie uns da so ein bisschen
mit geben uns einen einblick
also das ist schon sehr schwierige
situation ich habe vor zwei tagen mit
einem kurden telefoniert ja auch deutsch
spricht die harren schon seit sechs
sieben tagen im grenzgebiet direkt an
dem zaun zu polen aus und nun der hat
mir sehr dramatischen worten beschrieben
ist eine gruppe von 18 20 menschen da
sind frauen und kinder dabei der sagt
wir haben nichts zu essen wir haben
nichts zu trinken wir haben kein
frisches trinkwasser sie trinken
regenwasser und wissen nicht wie es
weitergehen soll und das aus meiner
sicht wirklich dramatische es gibt kein
vor und zurück nachholen können sie
nicht rein klar da ist die grenze aber
der mann sagte mir auch ja wir würden ja
auch wieder zurückgehen richtung linz
ich will hier einfach weg aber er hat
mir dann gezeigt und hat uns dann auch
ein video geschickt wo menschen blaue
flecken haben er sagt die belarussischen
grenzschützer schlagen uns wenn wir
versuchen aus diesem wald in der anderen
richtung wieder rauszugehen ich habe vor
einer woche eine familie getroffen die
es geschafft hat über diesen
ausnahmezustands region hinaus zu kommen
und die saßen schon drei tage in einem
polnischen weit und das erste was sie
haben wollten war trinkwasser da war
eine junge frau dabei die regenwasser
getrunken hatte und daran erkrankt ist
und uns ja das ist eines der
hauptprobleme dass bei allem politischen
themen die hier sind die humanitäre
krise meiner ansicht nach jetzt vor
allen dingen vor der drohenden
winterkälte zu eskalieren droht und das
sind ja wie gesagt von der polnischen
seite drei bis viertausend menschen
alleine jetzt sind wir in diesem
grenzgebiet in den wäldern polen server
von olaf zum abschluss noch eine frage
auch an sie als in polen korrespondent
bevor wir gleich danach brüssel schauen
wir auf die europäische sicht wie
erklärt den polen das dass man jetzt so
diese grenze so hart abschottet
ja also die polnische politische aussage
ist klar wir sind die bastion wir
verteidigen sozusagen den eines
eintritts tor nach europa also das ist
ja aus polnischer sicht nicht nur polen
das geschützt wird sondern der weg in
die europäische union hier ist eine neue
fluchtroute entstanden und die polnische
seite sagt politisch wir wollen hier
sozusagen europa verteidigen da wird
auch militärisches vokabular gebraucht
übrigens auch in richtung lukaschenko da
spricht man ja von an die briten krieg
den lukaschenko gegen die eu und gegen
polen führt da wird also schon auch
martialisch gesprochen klar ist die
schuldzuweisung geht immer in richtung
belarus diesen schuld an der jetzigen
situation aber wir hatten sie auch eben
angesprochen klar es gibt viele
hilfsorganisationen die sagen naja
eigentlich müsste man doch jetzt in
dieses gebiet rhein aber das zentrale
argument der polnischen seite ist klar
jetzt erstmal abschottung um die grenzen
europas an dieser stelle hier zu
schützen oder bord vielen dank für diese
aktuellen einschätzung von vor ort
direkt alles gute ihnen und meine damen
und herren dann gehen wir direkt weiter
nach brüssel sprechen mit unserer
komponenten in brüssel anne gellinek an
geben sie uns doch gerne jetzt direkt
passend dazu doch mal bitte den blick
und die perspektive der europäischen
union auf das was da gerade an der
grenze passiert
also ist herrscht einigkeit in der
europäischen union darüber was die
analyse betrifft der ereignisse man ist
sich einig lukaschenko ist der übeltäter
der belarussische diktator der bewusst
und absichtlich flüchtlinge richtung eu
lenkt um die eu zu destabilisieren
darüber ist man sich einig die frage ist
jetzt wie reagiert man darauf und da
gibt es durchaus unterschiedliche
positionen man hat es hier auch mit
einem sehr schwierigen partner in der eu
zu tun nämlich mit polen polen möchte
gerne eu-hilfe haben in dieser situation
versteht aber unter europäischer hilfe
in erster linie geld um die grenze
fester auszubauen mit stacheldraht mit
mauern
das lehnt die eu kommission ab mit der
begründung wir finanzieren keine zäune
die eu wiederum bietet hilfe an die
polen nicht haben will nämlich den
einsatz der grenzschutztruppe frontex
die ironischerweise in warschau ihr
hauptquartier hat und bis jetzt nicht
zum zuge kam polen wünscht keine
europäischen zeugen keine europäischen
augen an der grenze und hat deshalb
abgelehnt hilfe von der
grenzschutztruppe anzunehmen auch hilfe
von der asylbehörde der europäischen die
sagt wir könnten leute schicken wir euch
helfen die asylanträge zu bearbeiten
auch humanitäre hilfe hat polen bisher
nicht angenommen natürlich sie da müssen
wir vielleicht doch einmal würde ich
gern noch mal einen haken das haben sie
was sie gerade gesagt haben also polen
wünscht keine augen vor ort besprechen
ja immer noch von einem mitgliedsland
der europäischen union
warum wünscht man sich denn keine augen
vor
naja die polnische regierung hat ja in
der ganzen flüchtlings krisenzeit seit
2015 eine ganz stringente politik aus
ihrer sicht verfolgt auf keinen fall
migranten ins land zu lassen egal ob das
die verteilung von flüchtlingen aus
italien oder spanien betraf oder
griechenland oder eben jetzt flüchtlinge
die über diese neue fluchtroute
ausbilder russ kommen und polen
verteidigt das haben wir gerade von olaf
bock gehört verteidigt diese grenze und
sagt wir möchten selber entscheiden was
an dieser grenze passiert die vermutung
die man in brüssel hat ist dass polen
auf flüchtlinge die es geschafft haben
auf polnisches territorium über die
grüne grenze zu gelangen dass polen
diese flüchtlinge zurück bringt ohne den
ohne die mücken ihnen die möglichkeit zu
geben asyl zu beantragen
das wäre eine verletzung von eu-recht
ein sogenannter push back auch eine
verletzung der genfer
flüchtlingskonvention
polen möchte nicht dass eu agenturen da
dabei sind und natürlich polen dann an
klagen würden und sagen würden das geht
ja gar nicht nach unserem recht also
versucht die eu bisher nur mit worten
und sagt bitte
lasst uns doch da helfen euch aber die
polen lehnen bisher jedes hilfsangebot
ab was natürlich die vermutung bestätigt
dass die polen dinge an der grenze tun
die vielleicht nicht ganz im einklang
mit eu-recht stehen und was sagen dann
die anderen 26 wie viel druck kommt
davon anderen mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union und natürlich auch
von der eu kommission
also man ist sich erstmal einig das wie
gesagt dass das der es die schuld in
belarus zu suchen ist aber es gibt schon
auch kritik an der an dem handling der
polen dieser krise zum beispiel aus den
niederlanden zum beispiel aus luxemburg
die schon sagen wir wünschen uns auch
von der eu kommission wir wünschen uns
transparenz an dieser grenze die eu
innenkommissarin eine schwedin emma
johansson hat mehrfach sich auch mit dem
polnischen innenminister getroffen und
hat gesagt bitte schafft doch
transparenz die tatsache dass ihr dort
an der polnischen grenze diesen
ausnahmezustand verhängt hat habt keine
journalisten werden reingelassen
hilfsorganisationen nur bis zu einem
bestimmten punkt das schafft natürlich
alle möglichen spekulationen was da
passiert und die eu kommission sagt
lasst uns doch bitte euch helfen aber
bislang stoßen sie auf taube ohren
bislang sagen sie wie geht's denn dann
weiter und könnte sich das vielleicht
dann doch noch ändern
ja die frage ist welche druckmittel die
eu hat sie wissen ja dass die
europäische kommission gerade auch
sowieso schon im clinch liegt mit polen
wegen den problemen der
rechtsstaatlichkeit im moment sind da
also auf vielen feldern deutliche
konflikte weil vielleicht lenkt polen
auch deshalb gerade jetzt nicht ein das
ist muss man weitersehen auf jeden fall
versucht die eu das problem auf andere
weise zu verringern zu lösen kann man
sie lösen kann man es so schnell nicht
zu verringern indem die
europäer jetzt über eine neue
sanktionsrunde nachdenken sie nehmen
jetzt nach den ganzen personen die nicht
mehr einreisen dürfen und
wirtschaftsunternehmen die sanktionen
jetzt worden sind nehmen sie jetzt die
europäische die belarussische staats
airline will aber in den blick die
sollen die sind noch dabei flugzeuge aus
dem eu land irland zu lesen und mit
diesen flugzeugen aus dem nahen osten
migranten nach minsk zu schaffen die
dann weiter an die grenze gebracht
werden diese leasing verträge sollen
demnächst von sanktionen belegt sein so
dass das nicht mehr nötig ist außerdem
ist der vizepräsident der eu-kommission
der für migration zuständig ist wird in
den nächsten tagen in die transit und
ursprungsländer reisen und versuchen die
dortigen regierungen zum beispiel die
vereinigten arabischen emirate oder die
türkei zu überzeugen keine charterflüge
mehr zu unternehmen die migranten nach
mainz bringt das passt perfekt als
vorlage vielen dank anne gellinek für
ihre einschätzung aus brüssel und dann
gehen wir noch direkt rüber zu unserem
korrespondenten joachim moskau der
selbst viel in belarus unterwegs war jo
schönen guten abend nach moskau und dann
gucken wir doch direkter auf ja die
andere sicht wie sieht das also belarus
wie ist die situation aus deren sicht
naja da wird erstmal natürlich erklärt
sie selber hätten eben damit gar nichts
zu tun das wäre ein problem natürlich
der flüchtlinge oder vielleicht auch von
schleusern oder wie auch immer so
staatlicherseits hätte man damit gar
nichts zu tun hat jetzt auch gesagt weil
wird jetzt hilfsgüter auch in diese
region schicken schwer vorstellbar
natürlich dass das alles ohne kenntnis
und ohne zustimmung der regierung dort
passiert man muss sich ja überlegen
diese menschen diese flüchtlinge reisen
ein über den flughafen von münster gibt
eine passkontrolle dann kriegen sind
papieren hat visum das eben durch reisen
können dann müsste es ja erst dann sind
sie im stadtbild von vinz versammeln
sich da dann werden sie zur grenze
transportiert meistens mit bussen unter
den augen und unter den unter der
beobachtung der sicherheitskräfte dort
in belarus also natürlich weiß man
bescheid was da passiert und natürlich
da steckt natürlich auch ein politisches
kalkül dahinter nämlich letztendlich als
reaktion ist das gedacht gegen die
sanktionen die damals verhängt worden
sind als die ryanair maschine entführt
worden sind um eben den blogger potter
switch in gewahrsam zu kriegen das wird
als reaktion gesehen apropos reaktion
die europäische union hat jetzt reagiert
schon mit scharfen sanktionen bisher die
sollen jetzt noch mal verschärft werden
wie stark treffen diese sanktionen dann
tatsächlich belarus und den
staatspräsidenten lula schenken das ist
unterschiedlich also manche
wirtschaftliche sanktionen
beispielsweise konten einfrieren und
sowas von leuten das wird nicht so stark
treffen was den luftverkehr betrifft
also die die staatliche fluggesellschaft
bellaria beispielsweise trifft das
natürlich schon wirtschaftlich die ja
jetzt nicht mehr landen darf bella
coesfeld auch nicht mehr überflogen die
ganzen westlichen eu airlines und viele
andere auch landen auch nicht meinen -
das sind schöne aktionen die treffen
die frage dann die sich anschließen ist
natürlich auch welche rolle spielte
russland denn wir wissen ja dass
lukaschenko ein sehr sehr engen draht zu
wladimir putin erhält und da viele
beobachter ja auch sagen naja es
passiert im bilde wussten nichts ohne
dass russland hanna von weiß und es
zweitens auch genehmigt in diesem
speziellen fall jetzt wirklich diese
dieses albtraums der geflüchteten an der
grenze zu polen wie viel in wolfen wie
viel einfluss hatte auch russland
daher russland hat natürlich immens
einfluss offiziell wird gesagt wir haben
damit nichts zu tun belarus ist ein
eigenständiger staat langhoff der
russische außenminister kamen heute mit
dem vorschlag die eu solle ja ähnlich
wie bei den flüchtlings abkommen mit der
türkei der belarussischen finanziell
helfen damit sie mit den flüchtlingen
umgehen können in wirklichkeit ist es
natürlich so dass politischen belarus
gar nichts passiert was gegen den willen
von putin und gegen den willen des
kremls ist man muss es sehen belarus ist
zu 100 prozent abhängig von russland
sowohl militärisch aber auch natürlich
wirtschaftlichen vor allem finanziell
abhängig von kreditzahlungen von
vielmehr zwei fragen da vielleicht noch
die erste wie kann es denn da jetzt
weiter gehen also wenn sie die
sanktionen in teilen treffen in teilen
aber nicht wenn im zweifel politisches
kalkül sowohl von belarussische als auch
von russischer seite dahinter steckt was
wären wir denn da noch erleben jetzt in
den nächsten tagen in den nächsten
wochen auch gerade wenn es um das leben
der geflüchteten an der grenze geht also
das ist natürlich eine ganz bittere
geschichte diese flüchtlinge hängen fest
können nicht nach polen und können aber
auch nicht zurück wenn auch von den
wähler russischen sicherheitskräften
gehindert wieder ins land zurück zu
kommen da muss es eine humanitäre lösung
geben muss sich möglicherweise auch
polen bewegen und frontex zu lassen und
ein und einsamer geregelt dass
asylverfahren zu lassen und die andere
frage ist natürlich gelingt es den
fluchtweg dicht zu machen also gelingt
es die airlines dazu zu bringen damit
sie keine flüchtlinge mehr nach minsk
fliegen und wenn natürlich eine
luftfahrtgesellschaft da war die
androhung kriegt das der landerechte in
der eu nicht mehr bekommt dann wird er
sich schnell überlegen ob sie diese
transporte noch so durchführt wir sind
gespannt während der herren eine frage
vielleicht noch die dann doch am ende
auch ein eine vervollständigung des
bildes insgesamt ausmacht sie selbst
jovan ja ist sehr sehr vielen belarus
gerade auch in diesem und im letzten
jahr unterwegs sind jetzt nicht in
belarus woran liegt das das hat einen
ganz einfachen simplen grund wie alle
hier haben im studium moskau bei vielen
anderen medien auch haben keine
akkreditierung mehr wir dürfen nicht
mehr in belarus arbeiten westliche
medien sind praktisch nicht mehr
vertreten in belarus wir bemühen uns die
ganze zeit eine akkreditierung zu
bekommen erfolglos werden vertröstet
vertröstet vertröstet also man möchte
wohl in belarus keine beobachten wir
haben die dann aus dem land berichten
johanna wir werden das beobachten ob sie
dann auch noch mal aus belarus schalten
ansonsten alles gute in den abend
moskaus danke für die einschätzungen von
ihnen dank und grüße nach bonn